although the Spanish were the first
European colonists in the new world they
didn't remain alone in the Americas for
very long just three years after Hernan
Cortez captured Tenochtitlan the French
government sent its first explorer to
poke around North America and look for
what many European explorers had
searched for from the beginning a
passage to the east now although the
Explorers never found this Northwest
Passage because it didn't exist they
like the Spanish quickly learned that
there were quite a lot of riches to be
had in the Americas themselves in this
video I'd like to take some time to talk
about two of the lesser-known European
colonies in the new world New France
appear in pink and New Netherland this
little orange dot right here now you can
see that compared to the extent of New
Spain here in the Caribbean and Mexico
and expanding in South America these
colonial exploits were pretty small
indeed but I think it's important to
learn a little bit about them because
they help us see the ways in which the
different goals of colonial powers led
to very different types of settlement in
the new world and very different
relationships between Europeans and
Native Americans now though it's a
little bit hard to see on this map these
two colonies focused their efforts
around two rivers the st. Lawrence River
and the Hudson River which runs along
this little orange strip here
spot and along these rivers you can
still see the cities that were founded
by these colonial ventures like Quebec
City up in Canada and later Montreal and
down here of course the most famous
which started as New Amsterdam and later
became the city of New York right about
here it's the island of Manhattan on
which New York City formerly New
Amsterdam is located now looking at this
map you might wonder why was it that
Spain had these giant swaths of
territory really from coast to coast
where New France and New Netherland
really only followed along these rivers
at least to start with and the answer
really lies in this idea of goals and
New France and New Netherland sat on the
rivers rivers being the highways of the
world really up until the invention of
the railroad because they were primarily
interested in trade so let's talk a
little bit more about that French and
Dutch explorers were particularly
interested in gaining valuable furs to
trade from Native Americans living in
the northern part of North America that
they could then sell in Europe
long before European colonization began
beavers had been hunted pretty much to
extinction in Europe while beaver pelts
themselves were usually used to create
fancy hats this is a hat from a slightly
later era but you can get the sense here
that Europeans met on something of an
equal basis with Native Americans in the
process of the fur trade so Europeans
wanted beaver pelts and also the pelts
of other animals and often fish another
thing that was in great supply in this
northern region which is today the
Northeast United States and Canada so
how did this focus on trade affect the
relationships but
between Europeans and Native Americans
in the area well primarily they made
relationships between them considerably
friendlier and more cooperative than the
relationships between the Spanish and
Native Americans for example now
Europeans quickly discovered that it
made a lot more sense to instead of
sending hundreds upon hundreds of French
men to Canada to hunt beavers themselves
they could instead pay Native Americans
to hunt the Beavers for them and
consequently there were considerably
fewer French and Dutch settlers in New
Netherland and New France than there
were in New Spain and because there were
fewer of them they generally ended up
doing things more on the terms of Native
Americans so whereas the Spanish might
have used their guns and their war dogs
to force Native Americans to labor for
them the French and the Dutch were more
likely to observe trading rituals like
giving gifts and also fostering trade
relationships through intermarriage
French traders learned the Algonquian
language and married Native women and
had children with them so that they
could be considered part of the family
they even allied with Native American
tribes against their own enemies and
went to war with them as in the case in
1609 when French explorer Samuel de
Champlain helped Algonquians in their
war against the Iroquois unlike New
France New Netherland situated as it was
in this very good Harbor the island of
Manhattan was likewise very focused on
trade in fact New Amsterdam was a little
bit of a company town controlled
controlled by the Dutch West India
Company which sought to make the most of
all of the goodies that could be brought
from North America and then shipped to
Europe in fact you can kind of get a
sense of what the major
concerns of the European settling in
this area were from this map you can see
that they point out where beavers
turkeys foxes and bears can be found all
with their valuable pelts but you also
see that there's a extremely detailed
rendering of where many Native American
tribes lived like this detailed
rendering of what I believe is a Mohican
village the French and Dutch bothered to
learn all of these names and map all of
this territory because they cooperated
with the Native Americans to get to
these pelts it's hard to imagine a
Spanish map that would go into such
detail about native villages it's
important to remember that Europeans
were competing with each other for
resources in the new world hoping that
they could secure the best trade deals
for furs with Native Americans and
prevent other nations from securing
those furs for example the Dutch allied
with the Iroquois in the new world as
trading partners because the Iroquois
were the longtime enemies of the
Algonquians who are allied with the
French so just as the Europeans
recruited Native Americans into their
competitions to supply Europe with furs
Native Americans recruited Europeans
into their inter tribal feuds to supply
the Americas with European goods I want
to finish by just briefly comparing each
nations colonial goals with their
outcomes and what sorts of people
settled what their relationships were
like with Native Americans and even how
they attempted or didn't attempt to
convert Native Americans to a form of
Christianity now as we saw with Spain
their goal was to quickly extract
natural resources from the Americas and
to set up plantations for tobacco and
later sugar plus to convert as many of
the native people to Catholicism as
possible by force if necessary and it
was frequently necessary
consequently most of the Spanish
settlers who came to the new world were
men and adventurers who treated native
people with violence and enslaved them
in the in comiendo system and in some
cases had relationships with native
women and African women that resulted in
that very complex set of racial
designations we see in the caste system
but France and the Netherlands by
contrast came for trade they wanted furs
and fish and so they were very careful
to cultivate very friendly relationships
with Native Americans including by
intermarrying with them and a deliberate
and formal way so that they could take
advantage of having natives do the
hunting for them rather than having to
do it themselves so that really only a
few men came to New France and New
Netherland nothing like the numbers of
Spain and unlike the Spanish although
the French did attempt to convert
natives to Catholicism they rarely did
so by force now going forward as we talk
about British colonization in the next
few lessons I want you to keep both the
Spanish and the French and Dutch modes
of colonization in your mind so you can
compare and contrast English
colonization with both of them and as
we'll see the goals of the various
English colonies whether it's to found
plantations like in Jamestown Virginia
or to escape religious persecution like
in Massachusetts Bay that goal will go
on to influence not only who came to the
Americas from Europe but also their
relationships with native people